[Musique]
quand je lis ma puce, je glisse simplement mon
téléphone sur la puce, puis je déverrouille
et il s'ouvre c'est un pdf qui est
mon passeport couvert et cela signifie qu'il
est toujours accessible pour moi
ou pour toute autre personne qui veut vraiment
lisez-moi
par exemple si je vais au cinéma ou
dans un centre commercial, les
gens pourront vérifier mon
statut même si je n'ai pas mon téléphone
[Musique]
ils ne peuvent jamais dire où vous vous trouvez
ils ne sont activés que lorsque vous  touchez-
les avec votre smartphone,
cela signifie qu'ils ne peuvent pas être utilisés
pour suivre l'emplacement de qui que ce soit
[Musique]
eh bien, je pense que cela fait vraiment partie de ma
propre intégrité de me faire pucer et
de garder mes données personnelles avec moi, je me
sens en fait d'une manière qui  c'est encore
plus contrôlé
de mon côté de l'avoir entre mes mains